hello and welcome back to chess openings
explained as always my name is caleb
denby
and today i'm going to be taking you
through part
nine of the night or that's right we are
already through eight hours of
instruction on this one single chest
opening
and we are gonna keep on trucking
tonight
uh tonight of course i am covering the
sort of newest popular line against the
neidorf it's not that new
but it is sort of uh the thing that a
lot of top level players do these days
to get just you know a nice game against
the najdorf
i feel like from the white player's
perspective they don't have to know
as much sort of razor sharp theory with
this line and if black isn't careful
he you uh you can get into a little bit
of trouble here so what line am i
talking about
of course i am talking about the move
six h3 for white in the night or
so let's jump into it here and see how
uh
the players with the black pieces have
developed the theory in this opening
line
so to start off with we have a game
between sergey karjakin and maxime
vashir lagrav and a bug in the studio
but i will survive that
uh and this game i wanted to go over it
was actually a rapid game
from paris a few years back but it shows
how this h3 variation isn't actually
that
safe for white if you slip up a little
bit in the opening as sergey does here
so here we have sergey with the white
pieces he chooses e4 of course
we have c5 knight f3 d6
d4 c takes knight takes knight f6
knight c3 and a6 arriving of course at
the nidorf
and of course the topic of today's
discussion is the move
6 h3 so so far
in our night or series we have covered
all manner of sixth moves by white the
razer sharp bishop g5
the ever popular english attack the
fischer sozen with bishop c4 the bishop
e2 variations
i think we also took a look at some f3
and f4 nonsense
as well and in all of these moves
there's always sort of a downside to
white
committing to one of these moves with uh
you know the white pieces here so for
example
bishop e3 means that this bishop's never
coming to g5
it means it's never going to capture on
f4 in one tempo so black no longer has
to worry as much about those lines
bishop b2 or bishop c4 well then of
course this bishop is committed to those
squares you know it's not going to make
a second move
early on in the opening at least rarely
so and committing the f pawn to moving
can also be sort of uh dangerous for
white you know you're
revealing information to black with any
of these moves
so h3 is one of those moves that is
uh sort of related to the numerous
sidelines that white can play in the
night earth where
you sort of just you know take a second
on move six and say i'm not going to
show you too much
about what my intentions are i'm not
going to commit this bishop to e3 f4 or
g5 i'm not going to commit this bishop
to e2 or c4
i'm going to play h3 and i'm going to
keep my options open
and in the meantime h3 is going to be a
pretty useful move for me i'm going to
be able to prepare the move g4 which is
of course a strong attacking move
but with that being said i'm not
necessarily against playing f4
either so with the black pieces
what can you do against this move
well i'm actually going to recommend the
typical night or move here which is the
move e5
now one of the references material one
of the reference materials that i've
been using while i'm going over
the night or here has been the nidorf
simplified series on chesable
by alex korlovich and in that he
actually recommends
e6 and in the work that i did to prepare
for this lecture
i came to the understanding that he
probably recommended e6 because his
course is called the night of simplified
and e6 i think is a bit simpler for
black to play
and his idea is to play the move e6 and
d5 however
those lines looked pretty boring for for
black in my opinion
and i'm also not entirely convinced that
black was equalizing in all of those
lines
so why play a boring line that might not
equalize when you can just play
the straight up night or so pawn to e5
is my recommendation here uh now
thanks to white not committing this
bishop yet to e2
as we would see in some of the slower
positional variations white has the
interesting option here
of the main move actually in this
position dropping the knight back
to e2 uh and i think this
is probably what white should play white
has of course the option to step back to
b3
and we're going to take a look at this
as well and on a rare day
white might even consider dropping this
knight back to f3 although i think this
makes the least sense
with the move 6 h3 so knight d to e2
is what we're starting with here today
the main stuff and now
players with the black pieces have opted
for this move
h5 now why play h5 well
it's pretty obvious it's pretty apparent
we want to control the g4 square that's
why we stick our pawn
on h5 with h3 white says i would like to
play g4 and with h5
we say well good luck with that what is
the downside to this move
well chat room you tell me why in
previous lectures
have we avoided playing h5 this early on
there's a very important
reason why h5 is generally avoided
on as early as move seven
so what do you think chatroom
the chatroom thinks we should start a
chess tick-tock i'm not against it
not against it and yeah manny has in
general
the the right idea here the problem with
h5
in many cases is that we weaken the g5
square
now in this case after the move knight d
to e2
we're actually not going to be as
concerned about it the move bishop g5
definitely is playable
for white but it's not as scary
because this knight landed on the e2
square
uh very often uh in variations where the
knight lands on b3
you have to be a little bit more
concerned about this bishop g5 idea
because after knight d5
this bishop remains wide open and can
often step to squares
like c4 that is to say
with the knight on b3 i would be much
much more scared of this
than i am with this bishop here on g5
uh with all that in mind uh we are not
going to look at bishop g5 first we're
going to take a look at that a little
bit later in the lecture
instead we're going to look at the main
move g3 but just a brief word
on why h5 isn't always played on an
idorph it's because this bishop g5 idea
can be a little scary but we're not as
scared of it here
because this bishop is for the moment
hemmed in by this knight but yeah more
on bishop g5 later
for the moment we are going to stick
with this move g3 the main move for
white in the position
now what is the point of g3 well of
course white is interested
in putting this bishop on g2 supporting
this pawn from behind
and plopping a knight onto the d5 square
as white so often does in the nightdorf
how should black combat this well
luckily for black he's playing the night
or
and i was speaking with uh actually
dennis borosch
earlier today about the night earth and
he's like yeah
it's a great opening because all your
pieces just always have squares
and so as always we put our pieces on
squares bishop e6
we're not so concerned about f4 since
our opponent has wasted some time here
bishop g2 is the natural follow-up and
now after
b5 black has a perfectly fine game and
as danish borough said all your pieces
have squares
right your pieces just have squares to
uh to land on
white went ahead are in castle king side
in this game
and black plays the move knight b to d7
we're for the moment delaying developing
this bishop because the fight for the
d5 square is coming rather quickly so we
want to make sure
we sort of have all our ducks in a row
we have our d5 square well covered by
these two pieces
and this knight for reinforcement before
playing bishop e7 here
bishop e3 is the natural follow-up now
for whites just getting the pieces
developed
and finally black goes ahead and plays
bishop e7
in this game we saw the move knight to
d5 which is by far
the main move in the position you can
also actually see this move a4
but black is just going to push to b4
and we're going to get very very similar
positions here
just with these two moves sort of uh
inserted and the play is not going to be
that radically different
of course black is going to have some
play on the queen side with this
advanced b-pawn and likely some files
are going to open up over there but for
the moment let's stick with the main
move
knight d5 and here we have two options
we can take with the knights or we can
take
with the bishop and now if your goal
in life is to avoid long complicated
opening theory
uh sort of at any cost i would recommend
the move bishop takes d5
uh with that being said after e takes d5
and kingside castles for example
queen d2 it's true that black gets a
position
where you sort of just play normal night
or moves get some pressure on the queen
side expand a little bit over here
maybe knight b6 and knight c4 to follow
and you can sort of just play chess from
here on out
with that being said i sort of hate to
give up the bishop pair here
for the moment this bishop on g2
doesn't actually look all that
impressive but in the long run i think
it might come back to bite black
the fact that he has uh given up the
light squared bishop
so easily in this case so i do think
objectively
the best move here is knight takes d5
and i think it's worth playing
e takes d5 bishop f5 and now the
downside
is that this is a little bit more
theoretical and you do have to be
a little bit a little bit ready
yeah and hello to everyone hello hello
uh a couple questions that we're gonna
get to eventually but thank you for the
questions chat
thank you well we'll we'll get back
around to those hopefully
and now f4 is is the idea here and this
is why this line is a little bit more
theoretical
by capturing on d5 and losing time
with your bishop black for the moment
temporarily misplaces his pieces
and it's going to have to work pretty
hard to get everything
sort of back in order of course this
bishop on f5 is undefended
uh it is vulnerable two tactics
involving
f take c5 and rook takes f5 and of
course we just spent some time to even
put the bishop here
uh with that in mind though i do think
keeping the bishop is better
as i said and after the move rook c8
gaining a tempo
on the c2 pawn no time for this we can
take here
uh with an attack on the queen c3 by
white to preserve the pawn
and now i like the move bishop h7 g6 is
also playable
but i like the move bishop h7 and
from here black is doing pretty
reasonably well
in the game that we're going to look at
today sergey karjakin
goes a little bit wrong with his next
move
karjakin chose the move queen to e1
which on its surface looks like a
perfectly fine move
but it goes to show that if white is not
super well prepared in this opening then
white could very much get into
get into a little bit of trouble very
very quickly with natural looking moves
like queen to e1 so what should sergey
have
done well the fact of the matter is
white has already given up
quite a bit to black in this position
white has
cemented this pawn on t5 which at first
might seem like a good thing
but in reality this pawn is more of a
target than it is a strength on the d5
square of course later on a knight might
come to f6 or b6
and target it additionally the black
rook is well placed on the c
file black's pawn structure on the queen
side is perfectly fine
and white has not too much of an attack
on the king's side
in addition this bishop doesn't look
great this knight
doesn't really make a lasting impression
either
so since white has given up so much uh
white very much has to capitalize
on the time that black has lost right
away and i mean like right away
if white does not capitalize on that
lost time then he's going to be stuck
with uh the sort of position that sergey
got in this game
so how can white capitalize here what do
you think chat what should white play
immediately after bishop h7 you have to
strike while the iron is
hot and make sure that black can't uh
sort of solve all of all of the opening
problems
uh matthew asks what application i'm
using i am of course
using leachate.org
okay we have some suggestion suggestions
in the chats
uh manny suggests the move f5 why isn't
that word so hard to say
uh the move a4 has also been suggested
uh jason says y-g-o-f-5
i don't know what that means but maybe
he's also saying f5
g4 is on the cards bishop d3
is suggested i don't know how i feel
about that move
could be illegal and yeah f takes e5 has
been suggested so
f5 isn't really going to be the right
idea here
why isn't f5 the right idea well black
can again
solve some opening problems with bishop
g5
after something like bishop f2 to
preserve the bishop well then this this
pawn would be hanging right
if queen d2 perhaps this is better but
at the same time uh black is still
getting castled and we're not super
concerned about this move g4
because we can find some very nice
activity with moves like queen h4
moves like uh rook c4 and this pawn is
again going to be a bit more of a
weakness
than it is than it is a strength i think
black is pretty significantly better
here
and yeah same thing with g4 immediately
perhaps we can just take this guy
and activate our bishop right so the
moves that white
can play here are i think f takes e5 is
perhaps the most challenging
and the move a4 which sort of
aims for play on the queen side instead
so let's look at a4
first black can go ahead and get castled
white can play a takes b5 a takes b5
and then white goes for this move rook
a6 rather directly
and this is how white is applying some
pressure uh in this case
now uh white i think has won
one out of 17 games that we have in the
database here and the rest have been
drawn
and black is basically just fine after
the move rook to a8s
uh there's also a game between uh maxine
vashirlogrov and anish geary
that continued with e takes f4 here
knight takes f4
h4 and after bishop d4
maxime just gets this knight to eve or
sorry geary just gets the knight to e5
believe it or not maxim actually had
white in this night or
knight h5 bishop g6 and they went ahead
and repeated here
and so i don't think a4 is really the
most most testing line i should say
the reason for that is because uh number
one there's this rook a8 line which i
didn't actually look at too much but
number two
this line with e takes f4 which is a
little bit less common but
was played by nishkiri at the top level
should be perfectly fine
for black and the reason for that is
white did not have time to take on e5
and black is able to
sort of establish this knight on e5 and
with that knight on e5
black shouldn't have too much difficulty
straight out of the opening
so i think the more testing variation
rather than a4
is to play f takes e5 sort of while you
can a4
would be a great inclusion but i think
allowing black to take on f4
is a little bit too much for white you
get this strong knight on e5
and then obviously you don't have to end
the game in a repetition
like mvl and giri did but
i think black is going to be getting
some pretty nice play there with the
central knight
so f takes e5 immediately and now
what's the big idea well in a perfect
world black would love to play knight
take c5 get castled and sort of go about
go about business as usual however in
this case
now suddenly this knight on e2 which
looked a little bit forlorn
can spring into play with the move
knight d4 if you sort of continue
nonchalantly with castles
knight c6 is actually going to be
white's plan
and all of a sudden both of white's
pieces which didn't make too much sense
are suddenly making a lot of sense
knight takes c6
and d takes c6 and this is starting to
look catastrophic now
for white this bishop on the nice long
diagonal supporting the strong pawn on
c6
and black is going to be pretty
significantly worse here
so i think instead of knight takes c5
black
should play d takes e5 as has been
played
in all 30 games in the database i'm
using uh of course the downside to this
now
is that by drawing this pawn out to e5
white is able to play this move d6
and this i think is definitely the most
testing variation here for
white you get this strong pawn on d6
and now even though black's pieces are
all going to make sense
you have successfully opened up this
bishop on the long diagonal
you've given black a very serious
problem with this pawn on d6
and it's going to require a little bit
of accuracy by black
in order to equalize here that being
said
i wouldn't recommend this line if i
didn't think black was equalizing and so
after bishop g5 i think black
should do all right uh now there are a
couple things you have to look out for
here white could play queen d2
or bishop f2 after queen d2 we of course
would love to trade off the dark squared
bishops
black is going to castle on the king
side rook ad1 for example
and from here something like rook b8
queen b6
and aiming for an end game are going to
be
the plans for black you of course are
also
looking to open things up on the queen
side
a little bit and i don't think black is
worse here
at all i sort of ended my opening prep
here because black can play any number
of moves
h4 rook b8s bishop g6
uh queen b6 and and sort of be equal
from here on out after okay to d1
the key of course is to make sure that
this pawn doesn't queen and to try to
prove that it's more of a weakness than
it is a strength
black can also aim to play moves like e4
a little bit later on
to kick this bishop out of the game and
make sort of the counterpart to this
d-pawn felt
in the game as as well with all that in
mind none of this happened in this game
and of course i should briefly mention
bishop f2 it's going to be
sort of the same story here white's
going to play something like a4
and now we're going to look to activate
our pieces once again i think the move
b4
is actually the best here although it
has not yet been tested over the board
c takes b4 for example and rook c2 and
looking for x some activity here with
with black
and again the key is going to be making
sure this pawn doesn't get too far up
the board
and pressuring it just a little bit
while you still activate the pieces
and i'm not going to lie to you and say
that this position is
easy but i i don't think you're going to
be
facing too much deep preparation uh
beyond
this point i think at this point it's
just going to be a rather complex chess
game
that you're going to have to work out
over the board
moves like queen b8 though doubling on
the c file and yeah pressure on the
queen siding pressure on this pawn
are the common elements to look out for
with all that in mind
that is the main stuff however in
this game we saw none of that uh
in this game lee chess is
sort of hurting me here i cannot find my
main variation we're gonna have to skip
to the end and come back in this game
after f4 we saw rook c8 c3 bishop h7
as we were talking about and then those
two lines that i mentioned
were a4 going for rook a6 and some
pressure but i didn't think
it was too too bad for black because
knight e5 is a strong central knight
and f takes e5 which i thought was going
to be a bit more challenging with white
establishing
a pawn on d6 however the highest rated
game in the database
is this game between sergey koryakin and
maxine vashila grav
and in this game of course we saw the
move queen to e1
and i think this is going to happen more
often than uh
than you might expect right you sort of
always anticipate that your opponent
knows all the theory
and has outprepared you but at this
point we're pretty deep into the game
and i think expecting a move like
queenie won some kind of move
that just is that that looks rather
playable
and isn't these long forcing variations
it is perfectly reasonable so
queen e1 and maxime opted just to castle
which is perfectly fine
now rook d1 was the choice by sergey
karyakin
and now maxime takes this opportunity to
strike back on the king's side with the
move h4
so h4 loosens up these dark squares
for black for white rather we see the
move g4
and now maxime takes on f4 and i think
this is why
uh well actually i know this is why i
picked this game
to go over because it shows you what
black should be aiming for
here basically in this case we have
these downsides
for white where this bishop is stunted
by its own pawn
and none of the downsides that white
should be looking to get
from black we saw that the sort came to
d1 rather than try to activate along the
a file
we also saw that white was unable to
force d
takes e5 and getting this pawn out to d6
so if your opponent opts for something a
little bit slower a little less forcing
than those main variations that i talked
about
this is exactly what you should aim to
do with the black pieces
take on f4 keep this pawn here on d5 get
a strong central knight on e5
and activate your bishop along this
diagonal that's exactly what maxime does
knight takes f4 with sergey karjakin's
choice and now bishop g5
activates this bishop opens up this e
file as well
bishop d4 by sergey karyakin and now
rookie yate
maxime just puts his rook on the open
file and puts all of his pieces
on very natural squares clean f2 and
i'll bet you can guess the next move
just knight to e5 it's very very simple
chess
that maxim is playing but it's also very
very powerful chess he puts all of his
pieces
on good squares and that's what the
nydorf is really about
uh rook d to e1 is now played by sergey
perhaps admitting
that rook d1 was not the most accurate
move of all time
and maxime doesn't continue uh
with you know the most accurate uh moves
of all time
the engine wants to play something like
queen f6 but that move looks a little
scary he just plays natural simple chess
and it's good enough he plays queen d7
connects the rook defends this f7 pawn
and just all of black's pieces
are placed very very well with the
bishops on long diagonals
powerful central knight the rook on the
c file the other rook on the e file
and black should be substantially better
here and this is what you should aim for
with black in sort of all of these
variations just aim to have your pieces
on good squares
uh bishop e4 was sergey's choice perhaps
realizing that black's pieces were
better than his
he tries now to trade some of them off
bishop takes e4
rook takes e4 and now queen b7
and we're arriving now at the problem in
white's position this pawn on d5
is just a weakness uh a3
was sergey's choice but at this point uh
after rook c7 black is now threatening
to take and take with the f pawn
defended
we see bishop takes e5 trying to avoid
some of these lines
but now d takes e5 and this knight is
sort of attacked i don't know if it's
actually attacked but it's attacked
enough
rook f to e1 to make sure that this pin
is real
uh and now rook c4 increases the
pressure along
the fourth rank we see takes takes
knight g2
and maxine vishilagrov does end up
winning this pawn on d5
and i think this is very much just the
model game
for this variation in the night or
maxime
did everything by the book and sergey
sort of just got crushed for it
karjakin does win this pawn on h4 back
for it but of course the d
pawn was much more valuable than this h
pawn now we see
e4 in this pawn starts marching down the
board e3
queen e2 g6 to kick the knight knight to
d4
bishop h4 now and bishop f2 check
and sergey felt the need to sacrifice
the exchange
and did go on to lose this
end game uh and yeah that was the story
of the game
so i know i introduced those sort of
more forcing variations rather quickly
there
but that's just the type of thing that
you need to go over and
make an effort to memorize unfortunately
i do think however
that most of the games you play in
variations like this
uh in the six h3 mainline stuff with g3
are gonna go more similar to this game
than those games you must be playing
somebody
who's pretty well prepared to get all
the way to the end of
those f takes e5 variations the
important things to remember in this
variation
i'll go over from the top after h3 e5
if white plays the main move knight d to
e2 that's when we're going to put this
pawn on h5
to discourage the g4 stuff bishop g5
we'll talk about next
but first the move g3 is the main move
and here i like playing the move bishop
e6 there was a question in the chat
about playing bishop
e7 first and i think this is
reasonable but uh i do like playing
bishop e6 first in this case
uh the question was uh he likes playing
bishop b7 first because he always has to
think if bishop e6
is playable so he says in the chat but
in this case
with white playing h3 and g3 the move f4
isn't really going to be that big of a
threat here white has just wasted too
much time
and f5 isn't really going to be a threat
with this bishop able to step to c4
now so bishop e6 first i like a bit
better just because i want to defend the
d5 square as much as possible
because that is what white is aiming
after bishop g2
and now b5 by black and knight bd7
bishop e7 does eventually come and after
knight d5
the simple move i said was bishop takes
d5 but i think the best move is knight
knight takes d5
bishop f5 now if white knows anything
about anything
white should play the move f4 here
highlighting the fact that we've lost
some time with our bishop and it's
currently undefended
rook c8 gains a tempo on the pawn c3
bishop h7 defends this bishop now f
takes e5 should be played
and after d takes e5 d6 bishop g5
and we have a very double edged position
where white has this advanced pawn on d6
black is going to be aiming to target it
as well as
find counter play on the queen side and
in the center with ideas of e4 later on
and uh yeah white is going to be trying
to prove that this d6 pawn is a strength
by uh you know pushing it sort of up the
board also targeting things in the f
file
and it's going to be a rather complex
game
in this case though we saw white go
queen e1
and maxime thoroughly outplay sergey
after taking on f4
and establishing this establishing a
strong knight on e5 not right away
rather but here establishing a strong
knight on e5
and black was just significantly better
in this game so
i want to open up to any questions in
the chat room
of this variation in particular
or you know just this game between
sergey and maxine
in the first game of r6h3 variation so
go ahead chat
ask me any and all questions as i
get that back open uh on my phone here
okay we have a couple questions if you
play native 3 and 792 is there a better
chance
spent a night on d5 so we'll go over
knight f3
um actually i think close to the end
but it's actually not too too
challenging at all but yet
stay tuned for knight f3 after e takes
f4
uh can white try this idea of knight d4
knight c6 again
i guess so if you play something like
bishop g5 i mean sorry bishop f4
that's sort of going for this knight d4
idea but it is going to be a bit slow
here for example
bishop g5 can be played first if you go
knight d4 now we can take this guy
and after queen g5 then i can still come
to c6 if it well
sorry it can't here you have to defend
it first uh for example 95
and the knight can still come to c6 here
but well okay now i'm hanging knight d3
sort of showing you that there are
always
complications uh in the najdorf
the knight could still land on c6 here
hopefully
unless i'm blundering something but now
if you notice white has spent so much
time getting the knight here
that both of these pieces the bishop on
e7 and the queen on d8 have sort of
vacated
and this knight isn't doing much more
than challenging a knight on
e5 which is sort of not it's ideal for
example after the move
rook c to e8 uh i think white's best
option is to actually trade these
knights off you know
it's not on c6 looks great what does it
do not much aside from
contest the knight on e5 by uh by black
so you can still try to go after this
idea but it is going to be i think just
far too slow
can you not go b takes d6 with white
uh oh here interesting question
um no this is check
this is check this is a pretty classic
tactic in all of these openings
good question though i forgot to forgot
to mention
um okay am i a night off player well the
idea of this series was that you learned
the night or
with me so basically what i have been
doing
uh for those of you don't know because
the point of this series might have been
lost along the way
uh is that i have always seen the night
or
as sort of the mother of all chess
openings that are
difficult to learn you know it's sort of
the most complex it's heavily
theoretical the positions are very sharp
and so i wanted to take an approach as a
player completely new to the night or
looking at the various options for black
and picking the ones that make sense to
me
that were understood by me so
uh basically the idea was i would
find the variations that i thought made
the most sense to a player
starting just to learn the night or the
variations that can get you off the
ground
playing the night or uh from the get-go
and
trying to explain those in the hour so
no
i am not the most experienced night of
player in the world but i'm trying to
use that to my advantage
anyways enough questions we're wasting
too much time on
to the next game so up next we have a
game
between etienne bacro and marcus
rager and i've sort of skipped ahead
here sorry of course we had the regular
najdorf opening moves
the move h3 as always e5 and now i want
to take a look
at what happens if instead of the most
popular move knight d
to e2 if white plays this move knight
b3 instead so
after knight b3 should we play the move
h5
what do you think chat should h5 be
played here
so yeah x factor in the chat says he's
also new to the nightdorf and he's also
seen the nightdorf as the
sort of most difficult chess opening to
try to learn
and yeah you know the idea was that we
would be able to pick it up
together but now it's been like two
months and eight hours of lectures so
maybe i've only proven that uh
that it is a difficult opening so no of
course we should not play the move h5
why should we not play the move h5 well
now bishop g5
is going to be a bit tougher for us to
deal with
the reason being this bishop is not
hemmed in blocked on
f1 as we saw in the previous variation
and white's development is going to be
much more natural
than in the line we just looked at for
example if bishop e6 were to be played
and sorry we actually haven't looked at
the bishop g5 line yet we're going to
look at that last
something like f4 could already come and
things are just going to be difficult
for black
so the thing to remember knight d uh to
e2 then h5
is the move knight b3 is an attempt to
make h5
a little bit worse because these bishop
g5 lines are just going to be more
natural
for white so rather than h5 i'm gonna
recommend
the move bishop e7 bishop b6 is also
playable
but then f4 is going to be a little bit
tough once
once again and i understand that it
seems sort of arbitrary when bishop b6
runs at f4 and when it doesn't
the reason why i'm claiming it doesn't
run into f4 here
is because we see white waste this extra
tempo with g3
and put this knight back on e2 because
of these two moves i'm comfortable
putting the bishop on e6
here however after knight to b3 if
bishop e6
f4 this is actually almost a direct
transposition to something we have
looked at before
if black plays the move bishop e7 and
white plays the move bishop e3
bada bing bada we are in the english
attack and i have actually covered this
exact variation
however for white obviously he might
consider not playing the move bishop e3
here and then you're in a little bit of
trouble because the move f5 might come
and while i don't think black is losing
in this variation
i do think it might be rather difficult
to get total equality out of this with
white just having so much space on the
king's side
so early on so we're hoping to dodge
that by playing the move bishop e7 uh
and now there are actually two main
ideas here
for white if the move bishop e3 is
played
after bishop e6 believe it or not we are
just
directly in the variations that i went
over in my english attack lecture
uh just as a very brief review the idea
now is after f4
white has wasted time by playing the
move bishop e3 so we are happy to
capture
and play knight c6 and here black goes
to establish a knight on e5
support it with the knight on knight f
to d7
and after this stuff like rxc8 b5
knight b6 to a4 castle's king side
rookie 8 these types of moves are what
black is going to do if you want more
details on that
go watch the english attack lecture i
don't have all night anyways so that's
bishop e3 here
that's just a transpositional move that
would take you back into the english
attack after bishop e6 which is
perfectly natural
so what else can white do well what's
the point of h3
point of h3 is to play g4 right so g4
is probably what you're going to run
into more often
and after g4 black is faced with a
difficult decision
we would love to continue natural
development with stuff like bishop e6
and knight b to d7
but then the move g5 might be hitting us
so i like the move h6 here uh
just stopping g5 in its tracks for the
moment and after this
white is most likely just going to start
normal development once again
there are various ways to develop here
for black but
i have chosen a very specific way to
develop
that sort of kills uh white's attack
almost entirely in my opinion
and that's why i picked this line i
actually spent
uh sort of a a couple hours just
staring at different variations here and
always wondering why
it felt like black was on the the worst
side of getting intact
until i finally stumbled across this
idea by black which i do think
sort of uh solves solves black's
problems pretty
pretty thoroughly here so what is that
idea well the idea is to actually
in tandem with this move h6 start taking
over
all of the dark squares on the king's
side if black manages to take over
all of these dark squares there's sort
of nothing to fear from
white's attack so what's the way to do
that well the way that i found is with
knight b
to d7 uh now it's in white's best
interest to play the move a4
to stunt black's counter play on the
queen side before it ever gets started
and now the idea for black is to
actually play this move knight f8
and after queen d2 we can start with the
normal developing move bishop e6
or you can play knight g6 immediately i
could not find
a sensible difference between the two i
think they just transpose but we'll
start with bishop b6 because that was
played in this game
queenside castles and now knight g6 and
this is the setup
that i am recommending with black here
you bring this knight from d7 to f8 to
g6
and you are controlling the f4 square
and in many cases
the h4 square as well now white's idea
in this variation is to put a knight on
d5
to start with this is sort of goal
number one for white gold number two is
to you know
like come check mate black but goal
number one is to put this knight on d5
he would love to do so immediately but
this pawn is hanging you know tough
tough call which is why the move f3 is
uh
pretty much the only move that gets
played here king b1 can be played as
well but it's almost immediately
followed by f3 so f3 is the idea with
the point of knight d5
and after this black plays the final
sort of defensive move
knight to d7 sort of counter-intuitive
to give up this control
over the d5 square but now the point is
black is forever in charge of these dark
squares on the king's side
and that is going to be good enough to
[Music]
quite comfortably equalize here and in
some cases even play for more
white's idea was to play knight d5 and
white should follow through on that
so knight d5 in the game bishop takes d5
now
queen takes d5 and after queen c7
you can already start to see some forced
repetitions by white i think if white
doesn't start repeating here
white is actually going to be worse
which is why this this variation i think
is
is quite strong uh in this game we saw
queen c4
uh and now black actually very much is
not interested in trading these queens i
think black is going to be pretty
significantly worse
if black does trade queens and allow uh
allows this bishop to sort of just come
into the game
uh with a devastating effect so trading
the queens is a big no-no
which is why black sort of needs to play
the move queen d8 here
uh and then there are actually a couple
games that went queen back to d5
queen back to c7 and so on and so forth
however in our game uh white played the
move king to b1 here
and black now just continues with rook
c8 queen d5
queen c7 c3 to defend this pawn
uh marcus ragger just goes ahead and
castles kingside now
and now sort of the the time has come
for
white to accept a repetition uh if white
continues playing on for too much
longer uh you're gonna start to run into
uh some some pretty substantial risks
here so for example if white plays
something like bishop
e2 uh knight f6 can come all of a sudden
this beautiful d5 square no longer
belongs to you
queen a5 for example queen c6
rook h2 maybe uh and bishop d8
and all of a sudden the queen is running
out of squares queen b4 is forced
and black is ready to break in the
center with d5
so if you're playing opponent who
absolutely does not want a repetition
this is sort of the way to keep the game
going they just sort of
move some pieces around on the first
couple ranks you start taking back these
squares
with knight f6 bishop d8s and and
playing for d5 and this is the way to go
for for black i believe
now in the game in order to avoid ever
being worse
at tian pecro uh played queen a5 we're
still not interested in a queen trade so
queen c6 was played
uh queen b4 was played now and marcus
ragger just brings the queen back
to c7
now if white isn't careful black might
also go for stuff like rook b8 and b5
and white just went queen a5 and the
game was agreed to
a draw with this repetition sort of
being implied here
and you're going to run into a little
bit of this in in this sort of line
if black one and two here though you
can't actually keep the game going with
something like
queen to b8 and like i said still
playing for stuff like b5
bringing rooks to the open to the center
file and the c
file and stuff like bishop g5 is
definitely playable
as well here for uh
for black just as an example line
something like bishop b2
rook fd8 knight d2 bishop g5
knight c4 for example we could trade
these guys off stick a knight on f4
and this is sort of a good scenario for
black
but not a totally unreasonable one right
play bishop g5
trade off the bishops plant this knight
on f4 and your dark square control on
the king side of the board
is going to be very very good for black
in my opinion
and just a few more random moves for
example play b5
take a guy rick b5 stuff like this
playing for an attack on the queen side
and also making use of these dark
squares
on the king's side and yeah this i think
is just a very robust
defense for black here once again going
through it
if g if bishop e3 rather we transpose to
the english attack with bishop e6
if the move g4 well then h6 is the idea
and the line i recommend is this idea
where you take over all of the dark
squares
on the king's side of the board good
stuff any
questions on this one
ah and we have julian in the chat so did
i look at knight e2
and knight g1 i'm gonna level with you
julian did not look at that
did not look at that
weird having the queen on d5 and not a
knight well obviously
in all of those uh model night or games
by white
uh you they just plant a knight on d5
but
when black plays well generally that
knight should not be surviving on the d5
square or else you have
some problems we'll see
envy all nighter from the candidates um
i don't know dronis i don't even
remember has he already played the night
or
it's been like a year it's been like a
year how am i supposed to remember
what's going on
in the current candidates tournament um
anyways let us move on to our final
variation
of the night that i want to go over in a
game between
michael adams and look look i i never
knew
how to say his first name i also don't
know how to say his last name
but it is van vueli or veli
weli venueli venveli i don't know
anyways here's their chess game
e4 c5 and we have again the knighter
variation with
six h3 and e5
now i did promise i would briefly
mention knight back to f3
uh as i said i think this move makes the
least sense
with uh the pawn on h3 if white wanted
to play like this i think bishop e2
would have been a better way
and this is a much more sensible line i
think with h3
and the bishop on f1 white sort of just
gets a worse version of
this so if you want more guidance on
that type of variation i would recommend
watching the bishop e2 lecture again
one of them i think there were two
actually but just briefly i will mention
you just develop your pieces right
bishop b7 and white's attempt at an
improvement now
is putting the bishop on c4 instead of
e2
but we're perfectly happy to play the
move bishop e6 now and
just contest this uh diagonal like this
if white ever captures on e6
this structure as hopefully you know by
now
is generally just good for black we get
to defend the d5 square
and unless white plays some very serious
tactics right away
involving capturing on e6 then uh
and then black is going to be a bit
better here um and sorry i related this
line
to the bishop e2 knight f3 stuff but
perhaps it's a little bit
more sensible to also compare it to some
bishop c4 stuff because that's what
happens
in the fisher sozen but uh as
as in those bishop c4 lines as well you
always just put this bishop on e6
and try and contest the bishop in that
manner
just an example line bishop b3 castle's
castles go b5
knight bd7 and knight c5 and
uh yeah black is doing totally fine here
the only thing to keep in mind
is you should not hang this pawn with a
fork and rather
contest this knight here and this stuff
is
perfectly reasonable now for uh for
black
okay don't want to spend too much time
there because we've gone over stuff like
knight f3 before
and like i said i think it makes the
least sense in in this line with h3
compared to those other variations where
we see the knight go back to f3
anyways knight d to e2 uh h5 is the line
i'm recommending
and we took a look at the main variation
with the move g3
and now i want to take a look at this
move bishop g5 as
well uh this is sort of the principled
approach
to punishing the move h5 you say ha
you played h5 i was so clever with my
waiting move h3 i didn't even put my
bishop on e3 first
so i'm not wasting a tempo by putting it
on g5
now you look like a fool i will pin your
knight to your queen
take over the d5 square and black is
busted
uh which would be great if it were true
but i don't think it is
uh the line i recommend is actually to
go bishop e7 here i think bishop b6 is a
bit more popular but there should be
seven
uh sort of narrow narrows down the
possibilities quite a bit
if i wanted to recommend bishop b6 i
looked at that for a long long time
and there's just there's too much to
know and i don't
if if what if black goes wrong i think
black goes really really wrong if he
plays bishop b6 i think bishop b7
just a little bit simpler
so what's the point of bishop e7
well let's compare it to bishop b6 for a
second if black plays bishop b6 he has
to contend with bishop takes f6
and knight d5 queen d8
now the idea of bishop e7 is you can get
this position
but the bishop is on g5 instead of f8
and that seems pretty good so compared
to that
if black if white now captures on f6
goes knight d5
bishop g5 we don't quite get the same
position because our bishop is still in
c8
but i think this tempo is better spent
putting a bishop on g5
than putting the bishop on e6 because
after the move knight e to c3
bam look at that we got the bishop to e6
anyways
essentially what i'm saying is if we got
this position here after bishop e6 if i
can
and we could play knight ec3 if bishop
g5 were legal here
i would think black wants to play it so
that's the idea of the bishop e7 line
what's the downside well i guess the
downside is this knight g3 move
this is sort of the the other option
here and
for this move we are going to turn to
a lovely game between jeffrey zhang with
the white pieces
uh back in 2018 against somebody by the
name of
kovali ko koval koval kovalyav
kovalyav apologies to kovalev i feel
like that's a name i've read
but have never really had to say out
loud until this exact moment
anyways with knight g3 of course uh
white is threatening to step into the f5
square
so i think g6 makes the most sense here
just shoring up the light squares
white can then bring this bishop out to
c4 and things are starting to look a
little bit more scary here
on the king's side for black of course
we weakened our knight on f6
which softens up the f file and white is
now aiming
at many of those squares but i think the
way koval yav handled it wasn't bad
bishop e6 is the standard response to
bishop
c4 and it makes sense here once again we
are not too worried about this pawn
structure because it gives us good
control
over d5 admittedly this is a worse
version than normal because this pawn is
on g6
rather than g7 but i do think black is
still doing perfectly fine here
for example to continue i'm gonna play
knight bd7 stuff like queen b6
uh stuff like knight c5 and i think
black is
is doing okay uh bishop e3 was played in
this game
and now knight bd7 queen f3
knight c5 is all fairly normal stuff
queen side castles and now
in the game between zhang and kovalyav
knight after d7 was played and i think
this move is actually pretty bad
uh because after knight f to d7 bishop
takes e7
queen takes e7 bishop takes e6 is
actually a bit of a tactical threat
uh like i said previously f takes e6 is
the standard way black would love to
respond but because we played this
stupid move
now all of a sudden b4 is trapping our
knight so i am not going to recommend
you play the way that kovalyav played
with knight f to d7
but i do think black is still perfectly
fine if you start with this move b5
giving this knight a flight square and
ideas of knight f to d7 or maybe even
knight h7
can follow in many cases after something
like king b1
in improving move for whites something
like
b4 could be played but i like the move
knight takes b3 and this
immediately sort of simplifies the
position into something
that can very easily be evaluated so
knight takes b3
a takes b3 b4 now
uh hits this knights and rather than put
that
put it on d5 immediately uh white should
try and trade this bishop for this
knight i believe
and now after knight d5 bishop takes d5
rook takes d5
at first glance you might say hey wait a
second
this knight is to go there and my bishop
looks
bad why is black not worse here and
i think the reason that black isn't
worse here is because yes
given for free tempe this knight is
going to land on d5 and black's going to
be a little sad
then i think white would be better
however i don't think that that's going
to actually happen
because black has a very clear play a
clear plan rather
to get counter play by opening up this a
file whereas
white is not really busting open the
black's
king side too too quickly so for example
bishop back to e7 makes sense to guard
this pawn
something like rook h to d1 queen c7
knight f1 should be played starting this
rerouting maneuver
uh but now a5 for example knight e3 a4
and yeah i think black is doing fine
here rook b5 for example
something like ab3 cb3 even bishop g5
could be played queen a7
there are plenty of moves here for black
and black shouldn't be worse
because he does have this counter play
against the white king
and maybe taking a b3 is even a bit
unnecessary something like
five and in this immediately could be a
bit better
um okay so that is not the main move
though that i wanted to look at here
uh let's look at what happens after
bishop takes f6 takes f6 and knight d5
because this line
is actually a bit more common in the
database that i
am using okay
all rights a lot of talking tonight
always a lot of talking for me in my
lectures bishop g5 was the point we get
this bishop out to g5
knight e to c3 and bishop e6
uh now white should play the move bishop
c4 his whole point
is to really take over the d5 square in
this case
but now i think knight c6 is fine for
black as venveli
played in this game castles and g6 is
played anyways to again
just shore up some of these light
squares in black's camp
queen d3 by mickey adams we see kingside
castles
rook ad1 rook c8 now putting the rook
on the open c file and yeah uh
i'm playing through these moves pretty
quickly but by this point in the series
this is all stuff we have seen before
right uh i guess the difference is this
knight on d5
usually isn't around this long uh for us
to worry about
but uh black is just playing the normal
night of moves here he he put the bishop
out on g5 this bishop on e6
and he's looking to expand on the
queen's side you know it's stuff we've
seen
a thousand times before already it's the
typical night or
ideas that hopefully you guys are
getting to be familiar with now
uh bishop b3 by white to put this bishop
on
a less loose square and bishop h6
is vin velli's choice in this game
really black could play a number of
things here
king h7 is an improving move um
b5 is probably the one thing you
shouldn't do because a4 is actually
going to be a little bit annoying in
this case
but maybe even this black can get away
with
i'm just not super happy about weakening
these light squares
but yeah plenty of moves here knight a5
is also a
fine move king g7 is improving uh plenty
of options here
for black bishop h6 was just the one
that vanveli chose
and now knight back to e3 is actually
mickey adams choice
uh perhaps revealing that yeah this
knight on d5 is great and all but i also
want to attack your d6 pawn
and from here knight d4 was played in
the game to block off
this file and this is the reason why we
put this knight on c6 you know white's
sort of
wholeheartedly committed to controlling
d5 and in doing so has left d4
available to us bishop takes c6 f takes
e6 played in this case
and now white's big dream of controlling
d5
is sort of shattered by allowing us to
take back with this f pawn
knight e2 was played by mickey adams and
again his idea is to target this d6 pawn
but now after queen b6 by vanveli c3
finally removes this knight
we see takes takes and then here
black can actually do a number of things
including pass
bring a rook to d8s pretty much anything
here
is going to be fine for black but
vanvelli shows the simplest which is to
take off this knight f takes e3 take off
this rook
rook f8 rook d1 king g7
and this game continued for a while but
black was never really in
any danger here white is sort of
claiming that d6 is going to be weak
but with only two major pieces left on
the board it's not going to be a big
deal
black's king is never really going to
get into trouble white also has some
weaknesses to contend with
on the queen side and this is just a
total equality here
nothing really going to go wrong for
black in
this case and yeah i think
that just about covers pretty much
everything i wanted to talk about today
we did go through things rather quickly
so i want to open up to any questions
and very quickly i will review what
we're talking about here so
h3h5 g3 is the main move we covered
first
bishop g5 was played in this game i
recommend bishop e7
which is an improvement over bishop e6 i
claim because if takes takes as we see
in the main line
we get this bishop to g5 instead of
stuck on f8
the issue with this is that knight g3 is
a potential move now we've weakened our
g7 square so we should probably go
g6 it's also aligned with h4 but i don't
trust it so just go g6
and the idea now is that after bishop c4
we want to contest this bishop
put our knight on c5 and again go for
counter play on the queen's side so any
questions
uh dark engine says what do you do to
practice memorization
the variations are similar so it's
harder to in
ingrain the subtleties of each
so there are a lot of things you can do
for
sort of memorization uh i know like
chessable
is is great at this sort of spaced
repetition stuff that they talk about
but basically i don't consider myself
as having successfully remembered
something unless i remember the reason
why it's a good move so whenever i'm
sort of studying these these lines i'll
sort of say
not uh you know bishop e7 and then check
and see if i was right
i will say to myself in my head okay i
think it's bishop b7 but why would it be
bishop e7 here and if i can't come up
with that justification
then i haven't actually learned the move
so whenever i'm studying
i don't say okay bishop g5 bishop b7 i
say bishop g5
okay bishop e7 because of captures i
want to put the bishop on
g5 right and this is the difference so
if you
are able to tell yourself this
difference between
the line you play and the other line
then you
should be able to both understand it
and and remember it a little bit better
so obviously
that's rather difficult sometimes but
that's the best advice
i can give so if you have all this safe
somewhere in your you know various
opening files
definitely type in a note bishop e7
because or
in maybe you wrote it down by hand
because you're living in the 18th
century
bishop b7 because i want to put the
bishop on g5 that's that's the best
thing to do
um okay any other questions how long can
i study a move
to know it very well well when you can
sort of
recite what i've just said you know when
you have the justification behind the
move
ingrained in your memory as as well
every night earth game is a tactical
draw well of course as i
sort of showed in the first game um
we're sort of prepping for the worst
case scenario here which is
our opponent knows everything right when
the opponent knows everything
it's tough to play for more than a draw
with the black pieces but more often
than not your opponent is not going to
know everything to the end
and you're going to get games like the
first one we looked at tonight where mvl
was able to sort of understand hey
it's the nightdorf i put my pieces on
squares and i should be doing well
right and then he was and then he won
the game uh
okay so this is
the ninth lecture of the najdorf i wanna
give you a little sneak peek at what
we're doing
to next week for the grand finale
so this is our starting position of the
night or if i'm not mistaken
we have covered this we've covered this
we've covered this we've covered this
we've covered this we've covered
that we've covered that move we've
covered that move
but it is you know a complex
opening even though in the first eight
lectures we've covered
all of these main variations in to in
next week's lecture for the grand finale
we are going over all the sidelines
so stuff like the move a3 stuff like the
move a4
stuff like the move let's see what else
can white do
g3 could be played bishop d3 could be
played
stuff like this um there's others that
i'm forgetting about
but all of those tricky sidelines that
you
are going to forget about that's what
we're going to cover
uh next week and that'll be our big
finale we'll take a look at what happens
when white
doesn't play one of the main variations
so hopefully you guys are enjoying this
night or
series that is going to do it for us
here this week and if all goes according
to plan
we will have the grand finale of the
najdorf
next monday hopefully you all can join
me for that
and then we will move on to something
new the week after that you know
it's been a long long time we've been
talking about the night or i really
enjoyed it hopefully you have as well
if you are watching live be sure to head
over to the twitch channel now where it
will be
tactics time with yours truly i saw
talia doing some work on the tactics
earlier today
we'll see if she made any progress see
if we can make some progress ourselves
and if you're watching the youtube video
recording
once again thank you so much for
watching my name is caleb denby
i hope you enjoyed and i will see you
next time
you